use substitution to solve for x and y
and then give us a system of equations
here y is equal to negative 5x plus 8
and 10 X plus 2y is equal to negative 2
so they've set it up for us pretty well
they already have Y explicitly solved
for up here so they tell us this first
constraint tells us that y must be equal
to negative 5x plus 8 so when we go to
the second constraint here every time we
see a Y we say well the first constraint
tells us that y must be equal to
negative 5x plus 8 so everywhere we see
Y we can substitute it with negative 5x
plus 8 because that's what the first
constraint tells us Y is equal to that I
don't want to be repetitive and I really
want you to internalize that's all it's
saying why is that so every time we see
Y in the second constraint we can
substitute it with that so let's do it
so the second equation over here is 10 X
plus 2 and instead of writing a Y there
and I've said it multiple times already
we can write a negative 5x Plus 8 the
first constraint tells us that's what Y
is so negative 5 X plus 8 is equal to
negative 2 now we have one equation with
one unknown we can just solve for X we
have 10 X plus so we can multiply it we
can distribute this 2 onto both of these
terms so we have 2 times negative 5x is
negative 10x and then 2 times 8 is 16 so
plus 16 plus 16 is equal to negative 2
now we have 10x minus 10x those guys
cancel out 10x minus 10x is equal to 0
so these guys cancel out and we're just
left with 16 equals negative 2 which is
crazy we know that 16 does not equal
negative 2 this is an inconsistent
result and that's because these two
lines actually don't intersect and we
could see that by actually graphing
these lines whenever you get something
like some number equaling some other
number that they're clearly not equal to
that means it's an inconsistent result
it's an inconsistent system and that
these lines actually don't intersect so
let me just
graph these just to make it clear this
this first equation is already in slope
y-intercept form so it looks something
like this that's our x axis this is our
Y axis and it's negative 5 X plus 8 so 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and then it has a very
steep naked on word slope as every time
you move forward 1 you have to go down 5
so it looks something like that that's
this first equation right over there the
second equation let me rewrite it in
slope y-intercept form so it's 10 X plus
2y is equal to negative 2 let's subtract
10x from both sides you get 2 y is equal
to negative 10 X minus 2 let's divide
both sides by 2 you get Y is equal to
negative 5 X negative 5x minus 1 so it's
y-intercept is negative 1 it's right
over there and it has the same slope as
this first line so it looks like this
it's parallel it's just shifted down a
bit so it just looks like that so
they're parallel lines they have the
same slope different y-intercept we get
an inconsistent result inconsistent
inconsistent results they don't
intersect and the tell-tale sign of that
when you're doing it algebraically is
you get something wacky like this this
is why it's called inconsistent it's not
consistent for 16 to be equal to
negative 2 these don't intersect there's
no solution to both of these constraints
no x and y that satisfies both of them